All right, dear.
Well, before we go today,
it's time to celebrate some very special people born today.
Let's bring out the "Birthday Bunch".
(upbeat music playing)
(hands clapping)
I love it. We're starting two new segments today,
this day and pop culture and the birthday box.
I love celebrating a birthday
especially for people that we love.
Today, we're wishing a happy birthday
to the funny and talented Stephen Colbert.
(woman gasping)
Yes.
I love him so much!
(man laughing)
Well, did you know this fun fact about him?
Stephen can turn his ear inside out
and then he can wink and it pops back out.
(woman laughing)
So there you go. Fun fact.
I love that.
All right.
Well, a friend of the show, the bold
hilarious and brilliant, Lena Dunham, fun fact.
As a kid, Lena had four hairless cats.
And one Saturday a month, they all got basked
with baby share boo.
So happy birthday to both of them.
Happy birthday!
And beautiful music has sound tracked our lives
for over the past 50 years.
Stevie Wonder, fun fact.
When Stevie plays the keyboard,
he never uses his right thumb.
Wait, is that true?
I don't...
News crew?
I swear to gosh, thank you so much.
These are fun facts.
I live for this stuff.
And last but not least, another birthday
and it's a special drew gooder
in the bunch, Ilana Puglia.
She's a high school dance teacher
from Chesterfield, Virginia who kept her students dancing
on Zoom all school year long through the pandemic.
And guess what?
She's here right now!
Hi!
Hello!
(hands clapping)
Hi, hello now happy birthday!
Happy birthday!
Thank you.
Thank you so much. Hi!
What is your special birthday wish?
My special birthday wish is
to continue supporting "Arts"
and pushing others to do the same.
The pandemic has been so hard on the arts in schools
and as a school systems continue to suffer budget,
losses and focus on remediation,
I think the arts will be even more in danger.
So "Arts are Education" is a national campaign
that's working to support arts education
and I would just love for as many people
as possible to give to this organization
for my birthday.
(man coos)
Well, we'd like
to kick it off with a $1,000 donation
to support "Arts are Education" in your honor.
Thank you for everything you did for your students
over the past year, everybody's in awe of what you've done.
(upbeat ending music playing)